What's coming from my
heart right now is
maybe you're watching
this and saying,
"Hmmm, maybe I need to hedge."
You know, if you work from
8 P.M. to 4 in the morning
will your dreams come true?
No. You might not
be good enough.
You might've not
picked the right product.
But are we living in a world
2012 that's so much better than
your parents and grandparents
and great-grandparents generation
because assholes like me can make
videos when I'm
30,000 fucking feet in the air?
Yes. And because of that,
and because of
those opportunities
and because we're networked
in a way we've never seen before,
because sending an email to
100 people and 1 will answer
give you a shot matters,
because of that opportunity,
because of 2012,
I beg you,
I beg you to take a shot.